hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe in
meinen statistiken gesehen dass über die
hälfte meiner zuschauer nicht abonnent
von meinem kanal sind also klickt auf
jeden fall unter dem video auf
abonnieren wenn ihr den dünnsten content
und ganz youtube bei die fresse du
laufen allerdings damit welche heute
herzlich willkommen heißen endlich
wieder zu einer neuen episode
treknews.de und ich würde sagen wir
starten heute direkt mit drei extrem
süßen hunde videos
ihr seid definitiv jetzt hip hop famous
denn das video mit dem hund hier gerade
hat fünfeinhalb millionen likes bekomme
es ist echt und fassbar allerdings will
ich sagen starten jetzt mit den
richtigen tipp tor videos für die
heutige politik tuesday und zwar direkt
mit einem richtig systematischen
meisterwerk
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
episode ticket to stay
[Musik]
so leute
und jetzt wird jetzt 61 minuten fahrrad
versuchen zu springen dadurch dass wir
noch mal 1 60 brücken gegangen
10.6 will ich haben lasst das jeden fall
meinen leiten lassen auf jeden fall mal
ein leichter geworden das waren wirklich
gut dass ich niemals gedacht wirklich
nicht ständig ich glaub die freundin war
ein bisschen sauer danach
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kramer kapitel in die millionen
[Musik]
ich glaube ich hätte genauso reagiert
das ist der quality content sehen wir
auf sektoren paar sekunden später
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ach wie ich bei dir gern folgen
auf diesem schild steht reserviert dabei
wird hier gar nicht reserviert
das liegt daran dass hier etwas serviert
wird
da habt ihr nichts zu tun 36 es war ein
bisschen überspitzt dargestellt aber es
ist die wahrheit
ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist und
vor allem weiß ich nicht wie es bei
mädels ist aber ich mache immer komische
shampoo friesen unter der dusche
[Musik]
ja da jeder gerade zu hause bleiben muss
werden die leute definitiv erfinderisch
aber wo zu hause bleiben ich habe auf
jeden fall einen coolen tipp für euch
und zwar wird er euch im nächsten tag
doch gezeigt
[Musik]
dass es ein programm namens netflix
partien damit könnt ihr gemeinsam
zeitgleich mit euren freunden netflix
werde gucken also für die jetzige zeit
definitiv kommen
[Musik]
da
warum finde ich so was immer in meinen
vier empfehlungen
[Musik]
ja kann er kann nicht mehr die gleiche
frage stellen wie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und ich traue mir lieber vom fünf meter
turm zu sprengen
ich dachte
der autobahnbetreiber freut sich auf
jeden fall bin ich in
bewerbungsgesprächen was ist denn hier
[Musik]
das licht am ende des tunnels morgen
trotzdem in die schule und es dann
kannst du immer noch nach hause gehen
ich würde ich sagen aber es ist wirklich
die wahrheit
[Musik]
fremdscham pur gerade alexa was passiert
wenn jetzt das wirst du das auf keinen
fall
das ist lebensgefährlich für uns beide
[Musik]
und dem sieg doch kann ich euch gerne
das komplette video gezeigt allerdings
habe ich keine rechte an dem lied was
dort im hintergrund lief deswegen kann
ich das jetzt nicht komplett lang
abspielen allerdings ist er seiner oma
die wirklich jeden morgen gegen den
schulkindern im schulbus zu winter neben
geburtstag ist der busfahrer stehen
geblieben und alarm happy birthday
geschrien und der bus fahrrad das auch
noch geschrieben will ich sage das nicht
weiter
[Musik]
da bin ich genau deiner meinung gegeigt
einmal cording mitkriegt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe den richtigen sound effect ich
spiele immer kurz ab und jetzt hören wir
uns im vergleich noch mal seinen sound
effekt dass du kriegst von mir auf jeden
fall den synchronsprechern preis ich
frag mich einfach wie leute auf solche
ideen kommen und vor allem dass man auch
komplett einfach durch ziehen jetzt wird
es zeit dass man was finden was die
armen sketche
heute im supermarkt auch wieder so drei
leute vor mir jeder mit ihnen die acht
packungen klopapier
die leute denken die werden jetzt drei
jahre lang eingeschlossen in ihren
häusern aufgrund der jetzigen lage
möchte ich allerdings das letzte ticket
für heute auch der aktuellen situation
wird mit uns was ist ein kleiner appell
von mir an euch
[Musik]